second thing is Crash and we weren't
millionaires anymore we're back to JK
news right
you know what I like that that's the
base I've always been a Millionaire on
paper how about that that's pretty cool
that's pretty good always on paper
and and celebrity net worth
[Music]
uh crypto King Steve Green who's the
crypto King Steve greens somebody else
has self-described himself as quote
crypto King who's this Bob dude you know
he's a 23 year old actually is it uh
self-described Jim Cramer
who reportedly he's the stock King just
had his Lamborghini his BMWs and his
McLaren seized after investors suited
him claiming he stole 35 million DD
rockpool oh she might have rug pulled
might have but you know did he Ponzi
once I read through this I I think this
is actually kind of a fair conversation
it's a bit of a discussion I don't think
it's as one-sided as uh maybe we're
gonna make it outside I like open shunt
cases don't make me think let's make it
one-sided tell me who had a blame so I
can blame them Eden plotarski pleaderski
I don't know who calls himself crypto
King real original had two million
dollars of assets seized all right uh he
reportedly was given 35 million dollars
by a total of 105 40 investors now he's
being sued by former investors in a
bankruptcy proceeding and two civil
lawsuits whoa I mean at 23 years old
you're able to crowdfund that much
that's a that's a talent in itself yeah
this guy's good yeah he just used his
power for evil that's it how do you do
it so PowerPoint again with with things
like the crypto and the blockchain
community at that time I think that
there's a little bit of like needing to
set the foundation of understanding
everybody who's in that space
uh plays by a different set of rules
though you know what I mean the way that
they see money is different it's like an
average person maybe can turn like 100
into like a hundred thousand dollars and
they're not looking at the hundred
thousand dollars like a normal person
who works for a hundred thousand dollars
you know what I mean that makes sense
yeah like all came from a thousand so
maybe they still emotionally feel like
it's like a thousand and they're willing
to trade at a riskier level because they
made it so quick right right so the way
that people move money around I just
think it's yeah you know the feeling
look at it different you know what I
mean yeah many of us were like
millionaires on the blockchain for a
short period of time but it didn't
really change the real world the second
thing is Crash and we weren't
millionaires anymore we're back to JK
news right
you know what I like that that's the
basis I've always been a Millionaire on
paper how about that that's pretty cool
that's pretty good always on paper
and and celebrity net worth
well that's where Ryan's got us man Ryan
I'm the crypto King he's just wild he's
zany he's zany how do you think your
evaluation got so high because it's real
I don't know how that even happened
that's why he doesn't ever need to work
like he's like the least working person
out of all of us we keep throwing him
like responsibilities on JK news and
he's like yeah I could do it and I'm
like when you have time to do other
stuff man
I'm sitting on 19 million in unreported
income and he has all this like ex like
money to throw because he's always
buying us Donuts every morning as the
boss of this company I feel like that's
something I should be doing is getting
catering for the crew but like you're
coming here blowing guap on the Mochi
don't
know if I don't spend it then it goes to
the man so you know yeah yeah it's taxed
right off [ __ ] the man but he ain't even
getting the regular Cambodian Donuts
dude they're Mochi Donuts that shit's
like premium that's high ticket items I
want you guys to live the good life you
know that's the good stuff so investors
said that at least 35 million dollars
was given to plutarsky's company AP
private Equity limited and it went
missing 29 creditors have a bankruptcy
proceeding against poterski and say he
owes them almost 13 million dollars
including one 65 year old woman who told
CBC Toronto she invested sixty thousand
dollars that she was keeping for her
grandchildren's education
that's remarkable how did you get a 60
year old to invest in crypto because
like 60 year olds wouldn't they don't
even know what [ __ ] Bitcoin is this
guy this guy started investing in crypto
as a teenager
um obviously he was able to like turn
some [ __ ] into some real [ __ ] he got 140
plus people to give him 35 million
dollars like that's why it's it's a
little
it really depends on which side of the
sword you're kind of like sitting on uh
in terms of Rights and wrong yeah
because this happens all the time and
people just take the L right yeah kind
of because what's the grounds for what
you're actually even a rug pull like
like how do you even uh well I guess
mainly a lot of rug pulls happened in
the last [ __ ] like 24 months but like
what's the lawsuit realistically you
know what I'm saying in a in an
unregulated space that is not controlled
by the government or SEC these things
are happening and then claims are being
filled the filed that like x amount of
money is being taken for whatever
promise concept but you're really just
giving a bunch of money to a 22 year old
like what you know what I mean what's
the investment strategy yeah you kind of
know the risk once you're giving it to
them what's the difference between this
in any other business that people find
crowdfunding for like were there
promises made the differences are
unregulated
and and then also just the volatility of
the crypto market right like uh when
when like non-super heavy crypto people
are in the bull market that [ __ ] that
facade of all all is great is there
you're just blanketed by this like
never-ending possibility of of glory and
riches yeah but then you're not if you
haven't sat through a crash before
you're just not ready for it no matter
when no matter how many people are like
there's always a crash there's always a
winter something's gonna happen you're
just not sitting there thinking about it
every day especially if you're not
dedicating your whole life to it even
when you're dedicating a bunch of time
you still might miss the crash like some
of us did you know what I'm saying so
it's like I guess my question is more
like is this an Enron type of situation
where he did some Ponzi [ __ ] he did some
[ __ ] up illegal stuff or is it just
like he was a kid with an idea and he
was somehow it caught Wildfire people
were throwing money at them and then
like he couldn't he couldn't execute and
the business just failed so from the uh
I guess if if he's the defendant on this
his lawyer is basically saying that the
claims against him by former investors
are wildly exaggerated says quote
shockingly it seems that nobody uh
bothered to consider what would happen
if the cryptocurrency market plummeted
or whether Aiden as a very young man was
qualified to handle these types so it's
their fault for impulsively throwing
money yeah yeah because they saw they
wanted the riches right everyone getting
rich off because that's like okay I get
it if he was running a Ponzi if he was
running something really [ __ ] up then
and if that makes sense because he did
something illegal right but like let's
say this kid's like yo check this out I
got the next best thing it's gonna be
[ __ ] flaming hot Cheetos and you're
like no way for real and he goes yeah
but I haven't even made a product yet I
haven't even but I got a great idea and
then they're like I love the idea here's
[ __ ] five million dollars obviously
this guy is gonna [ __ ] it all up he's
never ran a company or done anything in
his life and then you come back to him
and say yo where's that play gaming hot
hot that you're gonna make what will
happen that's probably what happened but
then the Lamborghini purchase though I'm
just like should you be doing that on
bottled money see that's the that is the
harder part yeah what were their
vehicles that got Lamborghinis BMWs what
if it's his money what if he likes from
prior crypto [ __ ] that's fine I'm sure
he had like uh some earlier like
successes to be like hey look at I I did
great maybe it was this well that is
sure sure if that's uh what if that was
his money but I think the second you're
caught in both yeah then yeah you know
it's like well that's the world you're
playing in too right and he said he
sounds like he just was like at least
they're the prosecution's trying to say
that he was madoffing you know like he
was doing the Ponzi [ __ ] where he's like
oh invest money with me hey here's some
returns it went great but it was just
some other guy's money yeah in a meeting
with creditors potevski reportedly told
them he was quote very unorganized and
didn't keep records of his Investments
like all crypto 23 year olds his trustee
told creditors that platerski said he
lost the money he had received between
late 2021 and early 2022 in a series of
margin calls and bad trades
this is a familiar story to us
um right now placersky doesn't have a
criminal charge against him but is
facing the bankruptcy proceeding and the
two civil lawsuits but maybe it's
because again we're sitting in a room
where a bunch of us have made a lot of
money and lost a lot of money in the
same types of things it's kind of like
this seems like the end of the road for
people that are trying to like go
against go after this guy for the money
especially if he doesn't have it yeah or
if he actually did lose it which I get
why they're pulling his [ __ ]
expensive cars but if you go deeper and
he doesn't have the money he doesn't
have the money got it like y'all lost
the money too you know what I mean it's
kind of how it is it does blow my mind
though how many people get into this
space whether it's stocks or real estate
just investing in general and
um they act like risks and losses aren't
a part of the game so like in crypto you
hear people like always you know giving
out
like info advice maybe and then like
some people choose to take it and then
it doesn't go as planned or whatever and
then they blame the person that gave
them the info that's why I'm like don't
[ __ ] do it dude but there are people
that want to help others and they
[ __ ] do it and then they get burned
for it and I'm like that's why maybe you
shouldn't help people who aren't
investors
[Music]
people that don't invest like their
mentality for it
it's it is you could logically tell them
and they'll be like yeah I know it's
risky but they don't think it's gonna
happen to them yeah because they know
the answers and they they're like it's
not gonna happen to me because like I I
know more than everybody else yeah yeah
and then but they can't emotionally
handle it when it does happen yeah so I
was like I don't know man I
every single time people like how do you
do this how do you do that I'm all like
I don't know I'm stupid but I'll take
I'll take the advice and I'll [ __ ] do
it but I'll never blame the person that
helped me even if they help me lose a
lot but the fact that you got 140
different investors to give Matt some
money he's pretty he's pretty legit he's
clearly good at what he does it's just
20 yeah he just got caught doing it I
wonder what the pitch is how do you say
it how do you say it do you want to make
full-time money on a part-time business
come with me I'll show you how to make a
home-based business it's so planned I
want to make full time are you tired of
having a full-time nine-to-five job
are you
well are you this guy's pressuring me
man take my money how about you become
your own boss oh I never thought aren't
you tired for working for someone else
making them Rich well guess what be like
me I'm 22 years old and I already had a
million dollars by the time I was 20.
honestly that's that's a big draw like
it's just that's why he's buying all
that [ __ ] like you will invest money
with someone that's got a lot of money
of course yeah that's like you don't
gotta say anything with this [ __ ]
Honda CRV right with little Taiwanese
Flags it's like real it's like Realtors
you know like Realtors when they rent
like a nice car so that when they meet
you at the property they don't look like
a [ __ ] bum dude that is the funniest
thing to me because I'm like so so I'm
like dude you're irresponsible with
money you I know how much you probably
make and you're spending way too much to
look rich but that's because once you
get it you get it right but then maybe
like if you're not a Fiverr you don't
really get it so it's kind of like
people who think um when you when you're
part of a p pyramid scam you actually
are part of a business
because they dress like in suits and
[ __ ] they don't know right like you've
been working at a [ __ ] restaurant all
your life how would you know that this
is an absolute con like you know
especially if you're young
and then I think it's the same thing
with the whole like agent stuff right
you want to work with a successful agent
I just want someone that looks clean and
knows what the [ __ ] they're talking
about
I think that's the that's the key but
you got to know to know if they're if
they if they're talking about the right
shoes you gotta know about the sign
exactly exactly I also will I will judge
a man by his suit well what if what it's
like is that a Burlington Coat Factory
suit and a big five shoes like it's like
that Meme that Meme that shows that suit
that's like hella big for the guy and it
goes if you're a public defender looks
like this you're going to jail
if it's not enough you know what I I
judge more on the fifth if they know how
to [ __ ] have a right get it tailored
yeah tailored why if it's clean what if
he's like like that guy but then he's
like really good
tell me he just spends a lot of time in
his work then chances are he's not
though his chances are tells me he's
he's scattered he's all over the place
oh I see because like yeah like it
doesn't really matter about those things
right because what's what what's
important is is this person clean good
hygiene
um do they know what they're talking
about is their car well kept right so
like some people are like Bill Gates
where they'll have a Camry and they
don't give a [ __ ] about anything else
they have no fashion sense but they're
really good at what they do yeah the
anomalies are different right no there's
somebody that's like that don't look
like they could do it but they're like
the number one in the world it's like
okay that exception I'm totally but in
general that's why it's like chances
yeah chances are though like yeah it's
hard to go on the literally the point
zero zero zero zero one percent and base
everyone else on that but if you go
generally yeah if their suit sucks they
probably suck at their job
especially if they sell suits if they
come to a job interview 15 minutes late
with one one shoe on and a [ __ ] stain
on their shirt I trust that guy
hey breakfast yeah
responsible yeah
something to eat
he feeds himself
[Music]